whole lot weird Louise Alfredo a deal is
Marie yeah we're from Curitiba Brazil
we're celebrating our 25th wedding
anniversary and have booked a trip as
our gift we're traveling through South
Germany oh yes a musica murmur armos
a kettle vehicle ikea it will make you
feel i'd like to get to know the typical
little Germantown's porky by boiling at
home Grandma and Grandpa spoke often of
the towns in Germany how pretty Louise
it reminds me a little bit of Venice it
looks like I'm a miniature Venice but
was it flow zoom up we can cover in
years
[ __ ] is that house is crooked said I
don't believe them us feel like I drank
too much beer or too much caipirinha
look Louise what a narrow alleyway we'll
have to hold our breath to get through
boy now we're standing in front of the
own Minster it has the tallest steeple
in the world let's go in
boo boo it's very beautiful elegant and
tall really impressive a theorems of
that was owned and now we're continuing
to Alex born oh come along rub the
bubbles I think it's great that you can
visit two or three towns in Germany in
one day strays cidades as the distances
are small compared to Brazil state
automaton fit into the brands you torn
LM is so crappy Jean the Germans drive
fast b-baby really fast yep the coaster
our concerns about the booster are they
driving zigzags and are always changing
lanes possibility day toquinho dvd-r
there here we are in Augsburg else would
look nice that's Alex box Town Hall come
on let's look at the golden Hall it's
supposed to be really beautiful one now
wonderful
he'll really overwhelming but boy I'm
speechless I've never seen so much gold
I wanted that even the floor is
magnificent views with the real
in photography the Augustus fountain is
opposite the town hall with a statue of
Emperor Augustus oh we've come to the
end of our tour of ohm and Augsburg
everything was lovely it's a shame that
would have to go well mizane bought you
do now we're driving to Munich for the
next leg of our journey through southern
Germany Jose
you